un autre drame à Chambray-lès-Tours
cette fois-ci le corps d'une femme de 57
ans a été retrouvé sur la voie publique
dans le bois bordant l'écoquartier de la
Guignardière selon le parquet de Tours
la piste de l'homicide volontaire et
privilégiée une enquête a été ouverte
confiée à la brigade de recherche de
Tours et à la section de recherche
d'Orléans le mari serait ensuite et
activement recherché explication de
Lucas Chopin
il est encore tôt ce mardi matin quand
une résidence du quartier de la
Guignardière à Chambray-lès-Tours
emprunte le chemin sur lequel nous nous
trouvons pour aller travailler c'est ici
qu'elle découvre le corps sans vie d'une
femme de 57 ans habitant du quartier
elle aussi la victime se trouve à côté
d'une valise pleine de vêtements ouverte
comme si elle était en fuite en fuite
peut-être de son conjoint principal
suspect et qui n'a pour le moment pas
été retrouvé dans la journée les
enquêteurs interrogent les voisins à la
recherche d'un faisceau d'indices en fin
de matinée les gendarmes faisaient du
porte-à-porte pour savoir un petit peu
ce qui s'était passé si on avait entendu
quelque chose dans la nuit voilà on a
juste appris à ce moment-là qu'une femme
avait été retrouvée
morte dans un petit chemin à côté
aujourd'hui c'est la stupeur qui règne
dans cette éco-quartier pourtant calme
de Chambray-lès-Tours ça fait bizarre
c'est comme disent les enfants
normalement dans ton sac à la télévision
ou dans les films on pensait pas que
dans un quartier relativement calme et
puis se passer à un drame
de la personne qui avait vu le corps
hier matin en allant travailler la
personne était pour l'instant un peu
déboussolé donc la pape va venir grand
chose elle était en train de de se
demander ce qu'elle allait faire et
appeler la police les riverains à qui
nous avons parlé juste avoir peur peur
de tomber sur le suspect la procureur de
la République de Tours parle de ce qui
apparaît comme étant un meurtre et
assure que les investigations se
poursuivent activement pour en retrouver
l'auteur une autopsie avait lieu ce
matin pour essayer d'en savoir plus sur
ce drame